[Music]
hello
guess i'm doing a documentary right now
could you please give me a call back
what do i think about the city i
actually love it and hate it that's
chicago though it's our one big happy
family
the cries and the complaints of the
people
are ignored and neglected
jason van dyke is found guilty he'll be
the first chicago police officer
convicted of murder
what is necessary for chicago is a
vision actual solutions for the issues
we face rory lightfoot senses a late
surge and has won the endorsement of
progressives it is a breeding ground
for corruption what do we do that's
happens every time one of them get
killed they ride
it breaks my heart i gotta root for of
beautiful black children and they're all
trying to get out
but this guy pulled up on the side of me
and called me a black [ __ ]
you can't say anything without someone
being offended nobody's born racist it's
taught
i have no tolerance for sexual
harassment zero tolerance for six months
would you would you please let me finish
i
want to be strong chicago is often
called the great american city well i
didn't know economic development looked
like more investment in jails policing
and mass incarceration
chicago indivisible and united
for all
our lives